a lot of laws out there you got to know
what they are for example in Jersey City
New Jersey it's illegal to dump a body
in an area designated for body recycling
in Honolulu Hawaii it's illegal to harm
any shark that's in the middle of
attacking Dog the Bounty Hunter in Boca
Raton Florida any dinner served after 3
p.m.
is legally considered the following days
breakfast in Texarkana Arkansas if the
actress Millie Bobby Brown ever stops by
she'll be introduced to Bobby Millie
brown brown Bobby Millie brown Millie
Bobby Millie Bobby Billy and Billy Billy
Molly words words in Boston
Massachusetts all Wi-Fi passwords must
be Tom Brady in all caps in Sioux City
Iowa all good conversation lists will be
fined and asked to leave
in Paris Texas it's mandatory to refer
to the city as Paris but not the gay one
in Los Angeles California you can
present a pressed juice punch card as
proof of residence in Tampa Florida all
high school students must be able to do
meth on an eighth grade level
in rural Vermont if a guy shoveling snow
dies of a heart attack and if the
gravedigger digging that guy's grave
also gets a heart attack both men will
be buried together with the snow shovel
or on top in Buffalo New York anyone
caught eating a hot wing with a knife
and fork will be immediately surrounded
by waiters shouting well la-dee-da in
Baltimore Maryland
you got to let me know if you're gonna
finish them crab cakes hon and finally
in Huntsville Alabama
the law cannot discriminate against you
because of your race or ethnicity but
they're working out of my friend
that's a real thank you
you